BE ARRESTED BECAUSE THESE ARE
PROFESSIONAL, AGITATORS.
THESE ARE PROFESSIONAL
ANARCHIST.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT HATE OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: PORTLAND NOT THE ONLY
CITY FACING A CRISIS.
CHICAGO AND UNDER THE PATHETIC
LEADERSHIP THERE.
LIBERAL MAYOR, ALL THE CITIES,
LIBERAL LEADERSHIP FOR DECADES,
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT, LIGHTWEIGHT AT
THIS POINT.
VIOLENT CRIMES FIRE OUT OF
CONTROL.
THREE CHICAGO POLICE OFFICER
SHOT WHILE MAKING AN ARREST
COMING AS THE CITY IS FORCED TO
ADD 200 POLICE TO THE DOWNTOWN
TOURIST DISTRICT AND YET ANOTHER
SURGE OF CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
THERE.
CARJACKINGS, SOLD, STABBINGS.
MEANWHILE, THE OFFICE OF CITY
ALDERMAN, RAYMOND LOPEZ WAS JUST
VANDALIZED YET AGAIN.
THIS IS THE THIRD TIME.
WHY?
HE CALLED CHICAGO LAWLESS, FOR
FAILING TO BE THE OF CHICAGO.
JOINING US ALDERMAN RAYMOND
LOPEZ AND DAN BONGINO, FOX
CONTRIBUTOR.
YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT, AND WHAT I
HEAR YOU SAY IS WE’VE BEEN
WATCHING FOR SHOOTINGS, PICK THE
NUMBERS, WHAT’S IT’S GOING TO
BECOME A 60, 70, 80 PEOPLE SHOT.
HOW MANY WILL DIE AND HOW MANY
WILL BE CHILDREN?
YOU WANT YOUR CITY SAFE BUT YOU
ARE NOW UNDER ASSAULT FOR THAT?
>> YEAH, FOR THE THIRD TIME IN A
MONTH, MY OFFICE HAS BEEN
TARGETED.
I HAVE BEEN TARGETED FOR
STANDING UP TO THE GANG BANKERS
WHO MADE A MISSION TO TERRORIZE
MY COMMUNITIES.
IN PROTECTING MY RESIDENTS FROM
DEFENDING THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF OUR CITY SHOULD
NOT BE A PARTISAN ISSUE, BUT WE
HAVE SEEN TIME AND AGAIN MY
MAYOR AND ACROSS THE BOARD
ACROSS-THE-BOARD, POLITICAL
INCOMPETENCE FOR PEOPLE
MAKING EXCUSES FOR THE POLITICAL
POINT AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
RESIDENTS, OUR CHILDREN, OR
SENIORS WHO ARE DYING AND
TERRIFIED ON THE STREETS OF THE
CITY.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW MY WATCH
THIS, DAN BONGINO, AND I JUST
CANNOT BELIEVE THAT IT IS A MYTH
OBAMA SAYING, OH, THEY ARE GOING
AFTER PEACEFUL PROTESTERS WITH
TEAR GAS AND BATONS.
IT IS JUST A LIE!
AND THEN POLITICIZING IT TO THE
LEVEL THAT HE DID, WHICH, BY THE
WAY, IS PREDICTABLE.
EVERY TWO YEARS, EVERY FOUR
YEARS.
>> YOU KNOW, SEAN, I AGREE WITH
YOU.
I NEVER REALLY THOUGHT THAT THEY
WOULD COME WHERE I WOULD WAKE UP
IN AMERICA WHERE IN CITIES THAT
ARE LOSING BLACK MEN AND WOMEN,
WHITE MEN AND WOMEN IN DROVES TO
SHOOTINGS, PEOPLE BEING MUGGED
OR, SOLD IT ON THE STREETS.
THAT THE COPS WOULD BE THE
ENEMY.
THE COPS WOULD BE THE ENEMY TO
THE POINT WHERE YOU HAVE THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE REFERRING
TO FEDERAL AGENTS.
BY THE WAY, SEAN, THE SAME
DESIGNATION FOR FEDERAL AGENTS
THAT PROTECT NANCY PELOSI.
I DON’T KNOW IF SHE TOLD YOU,
STORMTROOPERS, REFERRED TO AS AN
OCCUPYING FORCE, LITERALLY.
THE COPS ARE THERE FOR THE
PLACE, FOLKS, THINK ABOUT THIS.
HOW DOES THAT SOUND TO THEM, THE
WORST DAY OF YOUR LIFE.
>> Sean: THEY ARE THE ENEMY.
JOE BIDEN.
>> THEY ARE THERE EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
YOU WERE ASSAULTED AND WHOSE
THEY ARE FIRST?
IT’S NOT YOUR MAMA, IT AIN’T
YOUR DADDY, IT’S THE COPS.
WHO BURGLARIZES YOUR HOUSE?
GOD FORBID YOU ARE KIDNAPPED OR
MISSING, WHO SHOWS UP?
THE COPS!
>> Sean: ALDERMAN, YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT.
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION, THESE
MAYORS, THEY ARE NOT DOING
ANYTHING TO PROTECT PEOPLE.
THEY ARE DEMONIZING THE POLICE.
THE POLICE, LITERALLY DISARMING
THEM.
YOU HEARD THE SEATTLE POLICE
CHIEF THIS WEEK.
YOU GOING TO STAY A DEMOCRAT?
DO YOU THINK THEY ARE PROTECTING
THE PEOPLE IN YOUR CITY?
>> I BELIEVE THAT THERE IS VALUE
TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Sean: WHAT ARE THEY DOING
TO SAVE LIVES?
THAT IS OUR NUMBER ONE DUTY.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING TO SAVE AND
PROTECT THE LIVES?
>> I’M NOT GOING TO ARGUE THAT
THE LEADERSHIP THAT WE HAVE IS
FAILING IN THAT REGARD.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
DEMONIZING LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
WE HAVE WORKED WITH FOR DECADES.
MY COMMUNITIES, LIKE THE
BACKYARDS WHICH IS THE MOST
DANGEROUS COMMUNITIES IN THE
CITY OF CHICAGO.
MY LOCAL POLICE HAVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE DEA, ATF,
FBI TRYING TO BREAK DOWN THE
GANG AND DRUG CARTELS AND IN
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS.
WE HAVE WORKED WELL TOGETHER TO
DO THAT.
WHAT I BELIEVE WE NEED TO SHOW
THAT THE PARTY --
>> Sean: THE PART IS AIDING
AND ABETTING ANARCHY.
IS THAT A TRUE STATEMENT?
>> THERE ARE SOME IN MY PARTY,
YES, BUT THAT IS NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF ALL OF US.
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN, OR THEY
WITH THEIR COMMENTS AND OBAMA’S
COMMENTS, ARE THEY HELPING?
>> I DON’T THINK THEIR COMMENTS
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, I DON’T
THINK THEIR SILENCE IS HELPING.
BECAUSE CHICAGO WHETHER DEMOCRAT
OR REPUBLICAN THEY WANT TO FEEL
SAFE.
THEY WANT THEIR CHILDREN TO COME